she's making millions of moviegoers
laugh as a weird Barbie but before that
Kate McKinnon made her Mark in the
fields of sketch comedy flag football
and international espionage
Kate McKinnon made her TV debut in 2006
on Rosie O'Donnell's logo variety
program the big gay sketch show
appearing on 23 of the show's 25
episodes the series was directed by
Amanda burst who previously played Marcy
on Married with Children in a review of
the chauffeur variety critic Brian Lowry
had this to say with Rosie O'Donnell
lending Marquee value as an exec
producer this production for the
modestly distributed gay cable net logo
rehashes the usual pop culture
references with only a few more inspired
exceptions ultimately it's another minor
addition to the every demographic will
have its own cheap sketch show Trend
Lowry ultimately concluded that the big
gay sketch show wasn't strong enough to
stick around for very long he ended up
being correct as it lasted only three
seasons
after the big gay sketch show ended its
run Kate McKinnon landed a coveted spot
on the NBC sketch comedy institution's
Saturday Night Live she made her debut
as a cast member late in season 37 on
the April 7 2012 episode and ended her
stint in 2022 at the end of season 47.
McKinnon often showed off some of her
most memorable characters and
Impressions on the weekend update
segment including Russian villager olya
pavlotsky and Supreme Court Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg her other popular
performances included frequent alien
abductee Colleen Rafferty and politician
Hillary Clinton the latter of whom she
played in nearly 30 sketches one of the
most memorable moments in recent SNL
history happened right after the 2016
presidential election when McKinnon
delivered a rendition of Leonard Cohen's
Hallelujah in character as Clinton the
following year on The Tonight Show the
real Clinton told Jimmy Fallon that she
was deeply moved by McKinnon's
performance which included a rarely
heard verse expressing the singer's
inner hopefulness and resilience Kate
McKinnon who is actually a better me
than I am to be honest really you know I
wish I had her her Talent McKinnon was
nominated for 10 Emmy Awards during her
time on SNL including two wins for
supporting actress in a comedy series in
2016 and 2017.
during her time on SNL McKinnon also
began to build up her film resume her
first widely released feature was the
2014 raunchy College comedy balls out
despite its lowbrow title the film
actually earned some decent reviews from
critics McKinnon played Vicky who has
run out of patience with her boyfriend
Caleb played by Jake Lacy she proposes
to him as they near the end of their
college Years the plot also involves
Caleb making one last grasp at his flag
football Glory Days by reforming his old
team for one last clash with their old
rival The Hollywood Reporter noted in
their review that the film cleverly
parodied boilerplate Sports films
including a Cheesy inspirational speech
from Caleb to Rally his teammates
following balls out McKinnon landed
supporting roles in several other comedy
films including 2015's sisters which
starred SNL Legends Tina Fey and Amy
Poehler and 2016's masterminds alongside
other big comedy names like Zach
Galifianakis
McKinnon's next major film role was in
the 2016 female-led version of
Ghostbusters which was directed by Paul
feig the rest of the main cast members
included Melissa McCarthy and fellow SNL
alums Leslie Jones and Kristen Wiig
McKinnon played physicist Jillian
Holtzman who designs and builds all of
her team's equipment the actress told
the New York Times that while she had a
keen interest in science there was one
significant issue that prevented her
from coming anywhere near her
character's career path as she explained
I've been a big astrophysics nut since I
was 12. I have always had a real soft
spot for the bizarreness of quantum
mechanics but I gave up on being a
scientist in high school I'm just not
that good at math I will never be a
theoretical physicist you need two
things in life a fog machine and a
glorious weirdo right wherever you go
after Ghostbusters McKinnon starred
alongside Mila Kunis in the 2018 action
comedy The Spy Who dumped me they played
Audrey and Morgan best friends and
roommates who are drawn into an
international Espionage Caper after
Audrey's CIA agent boyfriend son only
ends their relationship the film
received so-so reviews and did okay at
the box office pulling in just over 30
million dollars domestically and about
75 million dollars worldwide
McKinnon ventured Outside The Familiar
comedy genre for her next project as she
appeared alongside her future Barbie
co-star Margot Robbie in the 2019
docudrama bombshell the film details the
sexual harassment scandal at Fox News
that led to the ousting of Roger Ailes
as the Network's CEO McKinnon played
Jess Carr who works on The O'Reilly
Factor with ales accuser Caleb Hospital
who was played by Robbie Robbie and
Charlize Theron who played Megan Kelly
both earned Academy Award nominations
for their performances and the film also
won the Oscar for best makeup and hair
styling that makeup work actually
prompted an off-the-cuff reaction from
McKinnon that foreshadowed her future
collaboration with Robbie during a 2023
interview with Fandango Robbie was asked
if she'd ever been called a Barbie in
real life she then revealed that during
the filming of bombshell her co-star
made an unscripted remark that actually
made it into the film my character's
just like been revamped because she has
to do a first-on camera thing and I come
out and she goes wow anchor Barbie and
now McKinnon and Robbie have read United
for one of the biggest box office hits
of 2023 as Barbie raked in over 160
million dollars domestically in its
opening weekend and has already passed
the 1 billion dollar Mark worldwide
while McKinnon's look as weird Barbie
may appear haphazard to some viewers it
actually took a bit of forethought to
pull off as the actress explained during
an appearance on Good Morning America
it's based on the Barbie that I think we
all had were you'd cut the hair off and
burn the clothes and draw on it
foreign